wouldn't it be great to have a truly
jaw-dropping view
like windows looking directly into space
well it's time to build your very own
cosmic skyscraper
what would it take to construct a
building that reaches into space
how would you supply your penthouse with
water and power
and what would you do if the elevator
stopped working
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you lived in a cosmic
skyscraper
the karman line is the area that's often
regarded as the boundary between earth
and outer space
this edge hovers around 100 kilometers
above our planet's surface
living this high up you'd be one quarter
of the way to the international space
station
and your penthouse would be over 100
times higher than the tallest building
in the world today
the burj khalifa
this skyscraper in dubai
reaches a height of
830 meters
it would take about 20 seconds to hit
the ground if you fell from the top of
the burj khalifa so be careful on your
new balcony on a cosmic skyscraper
because a fall from that height would be
a much longer plummet to your death
or would you simply burn up like a
meteoroid entering the atmosphere
of course living in the sky doesn't mean
you can avoid the problems on earth
eventually all that pollution we put in
the air will come up here anyway
look we all want a better planet and to
make a difference for the next
generation and as great as going vegan
composting and recycling is for the
environment
individual action won't be enough to
mitigate the damage already done
look we need collective action from
civic-minded citizens just like you
people who will stand up to lawmakers
and corporations to make a change
whether you're pushing for the green new
deal or soda companies to ban plastic
bottles you need to use your votes and
your dollars if you want to fight
climate change elect the officials that
battle the issue now and don't support
companies that ignore this existential
threat
and remember no matter what let's stay
positive as we spread this message let's
educate and inform without resorting to
shaming or doom and gloom tactics
hey there's a lot of work to be done but
we can't make this happen together if we
clean up the earth below the view from
the top will be spectacular
in order to begin planning the tallest
construction project ever
you'd need to take into consideration
how big its base would need to be
with our current technology we could
build something as tall as four
kilometers
that's roughly the same size as mount
fuji a concept skyscraper like this was
proposed to help tokyo with its surging
population issues
it would have required a base as large
as 36 square kilometers
to go along with a price tag in the
trillions
a building that is 8.8 kilometers tall
or the height of mount everest would
need a base that's 4 100 square
kilometers
that's twice the size of the city of
tokyo japan
you'd certainly need a lot of land area
for the base of your cosmic tower but
even if you had all the land you needed
your issues would run deep
literally
[Music]
a tower reaching to space would be so
heavy that even the earth below it would
struggle to support it
it would create a ditch in the crust
over hundreds of years your tower would
sink deeper and deeper
your construction materials would be
another important thing to consider and
another issue that you'd run into is
that the materials you'd need might not
even exist yet
you'd want something that could
withstand all the gravitational forces
that would be pulling on it
one idea could be to develop a high-tech
form of carbon similar to a diamond but
stronger more flexible and extremely
light
but a luxury space tower made of
diamonds
yeah
you should make sure you've got the
budget for that
as for the windows that would give you
the most epic view
you could use aluminum oxy nitride or
ailon
transparent aluminum
this transparent ceramic-like material
made of aluminum nitrogen and oxygen
would be more durable than the glass
laminate used in spacecraft windows
you and your hundreds of thousands of
neighbors would have to think about the
structures utilities
such as water and keeping the lights on
luckily for you this would be a great
opportunity to put renewable resources
to work
you could build wind turbines into the
skyscraper's design
and so high above the clouds solar
panels would be able to soak up a lot of
raw energy from the sun
as for water you could pull it directly
from the sky around you
the troposphere holds nearly all of
earth's water vapor so you could collect
rain water and condensation from the
surrounding clouds
just leave some for us down below
going up to your luxury space condo
wouldn't be so simple either
you definitely wouldn't be able to use
the stairs if you were in a hurry
or worse if there were an emergency
theoretically a space elevator could
travel at speeds up to
320 kilometers per hour
at a height around the karman line you'd
need about 25 minutes to get from your
penthouse to the ground floor
maybe you'd have a faster commute if you
used a parachute
of course that would be if you didn't
burn up like a meteoroid in the
mesosphere
the truth is that living the high life
would come with some downsides
the temperatures along the tower would
vary dramatically
at the bottom of the thermosphere it
would be as cold as minus 120 degrees
and at the top of that layer it would be
a scorching 2 000 degrees
you certainly wouldn't be able to enjoy
a beautiful afternoon out on your
balcony without a spacesuit protecting
you from the extreme temperatures and
providing you oxygen to breathe
there would also be a constant threat of
damage from meteorites and broken
satellites
hurricanes or tornadoes
below you could topple the structure too
if your 100 kilometer tall building were
to collapse
[Music]
you could count on millions of tons of
materials doing an enormous amount of
damage below
maybe it would be best to start with a
project that could be a little more
useful
like engineering that space elevator i
mentioned earlier
but that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]